لا يزال الصحفيون حول العالم
يواجهون مخاطر كبرى اثناء قيامهم بعملهم
بل حتى خارج اوقات عملهم اليونسكو تعلن
ارتفاعا مفاجئا بنسبه 50% في عدد الصحفيين
الذين قتلوا في العام المنصرم ارقام تسلط
الضوء على الثغرات المتزايده في النظم
القانونيه في العالم وفشل الدول في الوفاء
بالتزامها بحمايه الصحفيين ومنع ارتكاب
جرائم ضدهم ومحاكمه مرتكبها بحسب تقرير
اليونسكو شهدت جميع مناطق العالم قتل
صحفيين بين ان منطقه امريكا اللاتينيه
والكاريبي سجلت العدد الاكبر من هذه
الجرائم اذ قتل فيها 44 صحفيا خلال عام
اللافته للانتباه في تقرير اليونسكو هو
نصف الصحفيين المقتولين تقريبا استهدفوا
خارج اوقات عملهم سواء عندما كانوا
يتنقلون او في منازلهم او في اماكن عامه
وهو منحن استمر في الاعوام الاخيره
الدوافع الكامنه وراء هذه الجرائم مختلفه
كالقتل بدافع الانتقام بسبب اعداد تقارير
عن الجريمه والفساد واستغلال السلطه
والاحتجاجات وهنا تبرز الى السطح مساله
الافلات من العقاب التي تثير الرعب لدى
الصحفيين وتعرض حريه التعبير للخطر في
جميع انحاء العالم فتقول اليونسكو ان
معدلات الافلات من العقاب على جرائم القتل
المرتكبه ضد الصحفيين لا تزال مرتفعه
وتعادل
86% من الجرائم
الامر الذي يحينا الى جريمه اغتيال
الزميله شيرين ابو عقله بدم بارد وافلات
المرتكبين من العقاب الى يومنا هذا
فالتحقيقات المستقله التي اجرتها الجزيره
ومفوض الامم المتحده الثاني لحقوق الانسان
والمؤسسات الاعلاميه العالميه العريقه
جميعها توصل الى نفس النتيجه التي تؤكد
روايات شهود العيان بان شيرين قتلت على يد
قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي صباح الحادي عشر
من مايو 2022
مكافحه الافلات من العقاب لا تزال مطلبا
ملحا بالنسبه لليونسكو والعديد من
المنظمات الحقوقيه والانسانيه والمعنيه
بالصحافيين التي تطالب بزياده حجم التعاون
الدولي على امل ان يفتح الطريق لمحاسبه
المتورطين ومنع اي جهود لطمس الحقائق في
مقتل شيرين وغيرها من الصحفيين